deutschland übernimmt immer den ganzen
deckel für das baugebiet europa gesorgt
so hefte raus mit schreiben ja wir
zahlen jedes jahr rund 14 milliarden
netto an brüssel mit sich die anderen
länder deutsche autos kaufen können aber
alleine zwischen 2008 und 2015 hat der
deutsche staat durch die eu
niedrigzinsen 122 milliarden gespart
plus wetter exporte nach europa nach
berechnungen der bertelsmann stiftung
hat jeder deutsche kind greis
erwachsener jeder deutsche seite denn
wenn margit pro jahr 450 euro mehr in
der tasche
im jahr kurz gesagt wir kriegen es mehr
aus als wir rein tut mir gut jetzt
angekommen
es ist so es ist wirklich so schäuble
ich hiermit ein beispiel schäuble
leipzig für zwei prozent geld am markt
und verleiht ist dann für fünf prozent
an griechenland und irland weiter
wir sind nicht der zahlmeister europas
sondern der kredithai sind der kleine
reiche streber den keiner mag
du bist ein kleiner reicher streber den
keiner mag
du würdest er ruhen broccoli fressen als
seiner kleinen schwester auch nur einen
keks abzugeben
dann wurde jetzt das sparschwein aus
echtem krupp stahl und curtis war
wenn das geld einmal drei komplett nie
wieder raus mit elektroschocks funktion
wenn der kleine franzose an der methode
da schäuble sparschwein für kleine
deutsche geld
[Applaus]